no the Chancellor and his budget said it
does not feel that families arming over
40,000 pounds and London should have
their rents paid for by other looking
people but as okay so long as you don't
MP endless budget the Chancellor also
abolished any housing benefit for anyone
below the age of 21 so we are knowing
that it that Euless situation whereby
because I am an MP not only am I the
youngest but they have know also the
only 20 told and the whole of the UK
that the Chancellor was prepared to help
with housing
we know have one of the most uncaring
uncompromising and out-of-touch
governments that the UK has seen since
that child